hi i'm eric boss and the latest dc
superhero film shazam won us over with a
heavy serving of goofy joy that seems to
be missing from the genre these days
and that bonkers approach extends to the
movies ending and post-credits scenes
now spoiler warning in case you haven't
seen shazam yet come on what are you
doing clicking on this video
scram okay shazam features two
post-credit moments
well two scenes after a teasery final
image
and in case you had any questions about
any of this stuff i'm gonna break it all
down for you first let's talk about the
final shot of the movie so after the
villain dr savannah is defeated the
final scene takes place back at billy
and freddie's school cafeteria
shazam walks in and talks up freddy
making him look like the coolest kid in
school
for being friends with him he announces
to the students this guy
taught me everything i know about being
a dope superhero true story
he says what's going on my best bud in
the whole world
and also new kid that i'm eating for the
first time but seems very cool and then
he says
i brought my other friend i hope that's
okay then we hear
john williams iconic superman theme as
the man of steel himself
strolls in with a lunch tray now we only
see him from the neck down
no face and freddie screams in shock
before we cut to the credits now the
reason we don't see superman's face is
contract disputes between the studio
warner brothers and henry cavill they
wanted to feature a full henry cavill
superman cameo in shazam but reportedly
the studio wouldn't agree to sign on
henry cavill to more future superman
films
and cavall's team was justifiably
annoyed that warner kept forcing him to
play the character in all these
complicated team-up movies rather than
a successful solo film like man of steel
was meanwhile the most recent of these
steam-up movies wasn't really received
all that well
and used this weird-looking cgi to cover
his mustache so in order to keep this
walk-on surprise in the movie of shazam
they had to use a stand-in and keep his
face covered but
ignoring all this stupid
behind-the-scenes drama this man of
steel cameo is still super fun
exactly the joyous fan service that
makes shazam so
great but let's now move on to the first
of the two post-credits scenes we see dr
thaddeus savannah mark strong in his
cramped prison cell
mumbling and madly scribbling the
ancient seven symbols as a way to try to
regain his magic
but of course it doesn't work perhaps
because shazam broke the wizard's staff
after sharing powers with the other kids
in his family savannah's pencil or
whatever he's using snaps and he screams
and he pounds on the wall
but then a voice calls out to him
hahahaha primitive simples
you walking talking monkeys with your
cave drawings
you assume there's only one way to gain
magic no
no no there are more ways than the mind
can imagine
and after looking around confused
savannah finally sees the voices coming
from a little worm on the windowsill
it's got a voice translator around its
neck i guess worms are kind of
all neck savannah asks what in god's
name and the worm cuts them off saying
i am the gods doctor not the other way
around
oh what fun we're about to have together
the seven realms are about to be ours
so i know some of you were like what so
this is mr mind
a dc villain and well known foe to
shazam
captain marvel he's also known as
captain marvel originally in the comics
in mr mind leads the monster society of
evil
not known for its subtlety but hey it's
comics mr mind is telepathic
and has mind control based powers which
makes the voice translator kind of
redundant but
so is the name monster society of evil
and again comics mr mind actually showed
up earlier in the film as an easter egg
trapped in an encasement in the rock of
eternity
but later when savannah finds the place
and gains the power of the seven deadly
sins the encasement is shown again
shattered and empty now i'm gonna go
deeper into why mr mine's appearance
could be important for the future of the
dceu but before i continue big thanks to
rage shadow legends for sponsoring this
video
read shadow legends is an awesome mobile
game probably the most immersive
experience you will find on a smart
device
honestly we should be comparing it to
the biggest pc and console titles but
this game is totally free
raid has all the features that you'd
expect from a brand new rpg title
an amazing storyline awesome 3d graphics
giant boss fights pvp battles
and hundreds of champions to collect and
customize guys i never expected to get
this level performance out of a mobile
game
just look how crazy the level of detail
is on these champions
geez uh i i would tell her to cover
herself up some more but
those are um skull earrings and i
believe they're human size
raid is getting big real fast so jump on
this to get a huge head start
there's also a special launch tournament
coming up with crazy in-game prizes and
real life physical prize packs
so go down to the description and
download raid only through our links to
get 50 000 silver immediately
and a free epic champion as part of the
new player program courtesy of the
developer team
see you there okay back to mr mind in
the shazam post credits scene mr mine
was first introduced as a super
intelligent alien worm from venus who
was attracted to earth's radio signals
and later on his monster's society of
evil was one of the earliest times in
comics that
past villains band together along with
mr mind on the team there was
dummy and mr who and ramulus it was kind
of goofy but it did lay the groundwork
for future entities like the legion of
doom also you could say the sinister six
or maybe even the suicide squad now in
the scene notice that mr mine mentions
the seven realms
this could indicate that mr mind is
being adapted from the more recent dc
comics in which he's
maximum his mind and he attempts to
control the power of the seven magic
lands
there's the earth lands the fun lands
the game lands the dark lands the
monster lands
the wazanderlands and the wildlands
where mr mine comes from by establishing
these seven realms mr mind is broadening
the dc cinematic universe
in the kind of way that movies like thor
did for the mcu with its nine realms
or another analogy could be doctor
strange with the way it introduced a
multiverse of various dimensions
accessed through magic mr mine could
also be the gateway to how black adam
could join this universe
black adam is shazam's primary
antagonist and in the new 52 relaunch
dr savannah is the one to reawaken black
adam from his tomb
black adam actually cameoed as a little
easter egg earlier on as a projection
and that projection did kind of look
like dwayne the rock johnson who's going
to be playing him in a future film
so by expanding shazam's world to these
seven realms
it's all but certain that black adam
will probably be part of this universe
and that brings us to the final
post-credits scene of shazam a jokey
stinger that rolls at the very end of
the credits shazam and freddy are back
testing powers including talking to fish
he says this to his goldfish
don't beat yourself up little buddy
you're gonna find someone
yeah i'm sure because there's plenty of
fish in the sea
now this scene might have been cut from
the power testing montage earlier in the
movie
because you may remember it from one of
the trailers i can't talk to fish what
could we do with that that's cool maybe
uh command a
an army of billions in the ocean oh yeah
and in this scene it holds on shazam a
bit longer as he says
well that's not that cool and you
probably noticed that freddie's wearing
one of his many justice league hero
shirts showing the aquaman logo
with this whole final stinger being
another shout out to the dceu
and i look forward to re-watching shazam
to catch all of the easter eggs because
boy oh boy there were a lot of them so
comment down below with your favorite
moment from shazam and follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos and
subscribe to new rockstars for deep
dives and all the stuff you love and for
those of you so desperate to see
superman's face in that final shot fine
look here he is
look see there's no head that's why
freddie freeman screamed
are you happy now
[Music]
you